how's it going everyone welcome back to
par whatever part it is I've been
missing you guys for a day what chapter
Fork
yeah probably is not here today and I'm
not on a flying of steam she will
probably appear once again we're little
I can talk we'll be doing more videos a
lot of more videos to get it so don't
worry about it I'm sure there's already
a lot of people being all like we're
it's probably why is pretty walking
backwards voyage I'm walking right the
way actually it's the Bassel I mean
smart comments subscribers what what
reload oh my gosh ah don't touch my but
I don't let zombies touch my butt well
okay just a little bit okay you needed
that you need a gang go to stop hitting
me touch my butt boobs what anyway we're
about to make some
it's gonna same video game history but
that solves wait too corny let's take
the elevator instead actually that's
probably bad idea what what oh that oh
dude that's so creepy no no no no net oh
oh dude you did you dude okay what then
huh no no no no no I okay let's make out
huh okay okay let's not make know okay
we're good we're good
all right so done no I'm fine I know I
can't go I wasn't scared there I was
just stretching my shoulders a little
bit oh yeah much better now
yes so we're gonna do this and we're
gonna click that clicking things is but
don't sneak up on me
clicking thing is so don't sneak up on
me
dude that's oh my god you gotta be
that's gotta be a joke what the okay
that was no they're not even funny with
I have no comment on that I'm not sure
what the [ __ ] it really or whatever
don't do that again okay sorry if we're
screaming
okay don't sneak up on me I got a
wheelchair handicap rights don't sneak
up on handicaps it's like the first rule
ever and don't make fun of handicaps
oh [ __ ] I forgot that girl okay why is
or a lot don't sneak up on me don't
sneak up on me I'll do okay I got
revolver animal that's good shut up
sorry I didn't mean you guys you can't
see we're talking I don't know are you
talking to me in my videos actually a
lot of people comment saying that what
balls everywhere and your whatever I'll
do I hope that I just die you pieces of
sexy gloves though I like your glass I
got to give you credit for that all
right you guys are dead and I'm alpha
all right okay we got that clear now so
let's move out
shall we salute okay pull the sneak up
on why am i walking in circles am I
supposed to take the elevator okay
elevate pony
they penetrate that's through beige I
can't think of good words my mom
what okay um yeah sorry for it so it's
starting now
[Music]
okay why am I keep walking in freakin
dude
nope we did don't okay I got this sneaky
sneaky frickin in yeah nope I'm not a
sneaking in yeah I'm not a second in yet
yep okay it's fine it's fine
I still anemia in training Oh for under
and my family okay good sneaky new yeah
why are the heck that okay I got this I
got this no problem
[ __ ] okay we good
what am i doing in here come on what
doesn't work hitting stuff with your ex
usually works you click this let's stop
nice nice I gotta do it I got it oh yes
okay just once that's fine
this one nope nope nope Edvin up okay
Lucia let's take the blue share first
I'll give you a blue share you don't
okay that wasn't that creepy though
okay this is creepy nope I kind of knew
what was gonna happen okay okay nope
what is in here locked like everything
else okay
good thing we got the blue shirt you're
coming with me you're actually a bro
don't sneak up on me don't you dare
sneak up on me don't spare key oh my
blue share your bro don't why are you
making out with that freaking yours
how do I get up there okay sorry
handicap presents
I don't know why it wouldn't be offended
by that you're coming with me
you better believe it Oh Oh No there's
something around the corner we share you
check what it is is your mom is she hot
oh dude what the [ __ ] Oh what the [ __ ]
anyone there
do share you shake okay it's fine blue
shirt huh
there nope did I miss something scary
good you're sure
good job dude Louie I'll call you mr.
blue
no mr. hoo what don't like that name for
penalty what the heck what happened okay
wait
I got this mr. blue me and you miss the
blue I love me and I love you what no no
no no no closing in on me okay well just
go in here then it's fine no problem
problem okay was this no flashlight I
need you okay no it's the blue
Oh what I'm playing I thought was got
seen ah this again I hate this oh gosh
okay that I'm glad I'm not there anymore
therefore dirt
there's the third there apparently
dep dep dep dep dep dep dep dep dep dep
dep dep x that dope dope dope dope dope
dope dope dope dope dope dope dope dope
dope dope dope a lot of they trust
someone with a freshness a nice is that
a you know um huh my um okay they let me
go first oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
okay it's all it's all bring it bring it
bring it bring it bring it okay it's all
Pepa dirt it's all okay no problem
I'll go first I'm freaking out fine you
guys are beta I'm alpha I was born alpha
I'll just open the door before me please
no disturb me but the dirt
[Music]
you